each other this month I think is refire
but especially with YouTube I really
like you too I feel like I really click
with you guys I was like hey Nashville
Tennessee right here in the place where
we got inducted to the hope a great room
right here we're on announced the world
tour today the stadium tour this is
gonna be fun good I wanted to call the
big a stadium tour
it's a stadium tour above is all the
information on it but what we talked
about today is we're gonna introduce
five cities before Christmas to go on
sale because on the inside see Yugi you
guys asked for a longer planning date so
you can plan to be it what are you
showing you Jamie
oh that comes first two cities st.
louis's where we're kicking it off of
man you watch it it's so weird Phoenix
Glendale Arizona Cardinals play this is
native Stadium as well so those are the
first two the other three will be
announced here shortly and again they'll
all be on sale before Christmas and
remember this is all about game day - oh
it's or Garth day in day or Garth day
however you want to look at it compress
on your full color support your team
let's go have some fun and let's get
physical playing music by the way we
guys say this Garth is an amazing
performer he's so many people's favorite
he's the top-selling act and he sells
more tickets than Beyonce okay okay that
dude is other level they sold out more
Notre Dame Stadium in like under a
[ __ ] hour like just unbelievable like
it's out of control he's been so famous
for so long that I think he really
thinks like what didn't what are normal
people like you know
which is a model whiskey be like I don't
know ten grand [ __ ] have any idea in
his social media is really awkward and
it's the best thing in the world from
the announcement that social with that
Facebook one that you know was increase
all that one he's like what guess it's
official
but Christina just posted this video I'm
obsessed with the Garth Brooks and it's
so [ __ ] amazing it's amazing it's one
of the best videos I've ever again
hashtag ass Garth ask me anything
okay hashtag happy hashtag hashtag
mister year what I loved was that you're
it you're he does that he does this he
also know he's so famous and his his
wife's famous but she's not yes wait
what
yes mister Yearwood so he does that
thing where he's like I'm mister you're
what I took my wife's letter before the
you know just cuz I'm just like y'all my
wife's first name to marry Trisha
Yearwood yeah yeah they've married for a
while okay go ahead yeah yeah great
winners he's just he's just I think he's
very sincere
I believe it but there's something
[ __ ] weird going on there and I think
he's got a couple bodies in the trunk I
just don't I think there's something
going on I think it's somebody you know
how how there's something about like
when you watch or you remember back to
Michael Jackson and you're like that guy
got weird for obviously yeah but also
how incomprehensible is it to be as
famous as he is yeah yeah or was Michael
Jackson Garth Brooks like for me the
part that's that's a reach or whatever
is that none of my friends are ever like
amen
do you hear that new Garth Brooks track
like I don't have anyone in my life
talking about him so
seems almost like a like a foreign
entity right like I just go the country
fans
did you ever yeah I don't know any of it
sure all-time fun drinking song that's
one of them it's close to relax yeah and
not worry about which [ __ ] rednecks
yeah
drunk enough to relax you have a couple
tequila's in you I can appreciate you I
have I want some Clint black [ __ ] I have
some Hank Williams stuff I'm not
knocking it all together I'm just saying
he's not somebody that regularly or that
I even talked to someone was like going
to Garth Brooks is Waylon Jetta so we're
the Jennings but his social media is
that special it is remarkable amazing
it's amazing it's amazing he has a show
where like he whenever he's so famous
the he'll just post he'll be like we're
inside Studio G right now
he calls it Studio G yes I'm I'm already
doing he does funny like he does weird
waves where he doesn't know how to end a
video so he'll just be like CV at this
stadium this weekend it's hilarious I've
ever seen it is pretty [ __ ] amazing
I'm obsessed with it now and I found it
through him and push yeah it's it's
right and I don't know if he's kind of
video yet but even you know Vic Berger
the editor he's so he's the best
I don't know how he pulled he just pulls
the best content edits it amazingly and
he put up a bunch of Garth's Instagram
stuff it's great or just go to we should
do a stadium tour where we just get get
comfortable
music let's get physical' out there
while we're making me like that
what let's get physical' who are doing
comedy I like that you are comedy you
know what call me physical because I
here's the thing he was like we're gonna
do with this in stadiums were normally
you see football teams so we're your
favorite football teams uniform and then
let's get physical while we're making
you know what is weird about you know
like my dad would say